you know when you look at the game i i
have a tremendous amount of respect for
the bill's defense uh but in a lot of
instances it wasn't like we were
struggling to move the football
um you know we we kind of ended up
having some self-inflicted wounds and i
say that knowing that they created a lot
of those things there was absolutely no
panic on the headset from our players on
the sideline from our players in the
field
just a lot of calm and
you know whether it's josh in this case
or any other player staff member just
like we've like we've been there a
number of times before and that's that's
awesome
all right the two coaches from a fairly
compelling week three game in buffalo
rams in the bill sean mcveigh ultimately
lost although he could have won sean
mcdermott won although he should have
lost after his team squandered the most
dangerous lead in football 28-3 that was
the subject of this week's re-watch and
shireen and i both went back watch the
game carefully and we've got some takes
based upon what we saw let's begin with
the best player on the field for either
team shireen who do you have
well i'm going with josh allen just the
way he handled losing that lead and then
coming back i'm not sure what's more
impressive the fact that they jumped out
to such a big lead or the fact that he
brought him back but both were equally
impressive i mean he just played really
well 311 yards four touchdowns an
interception that really wasn't an
interception it's unfortunate that was
the turning point in the entire game and
it's unfortunate that was called an
interception tyler croft did push off
but tyler croft had that ball
simultaneous possession it should have
gone to the offense and then in which
case you penalized the bills for pushing
off offensive past interference and they
didn't do that but just a great game by
josh allen and i can't say i've watched
very many josh allen games but he he was
so good in this game hit seven different
receivers lost john brown at one point
it didn't matter uh 10 touchdowns one
interception this season and in the
second highest pass rating i just was
really impressed with with how he
handled everything in this game other
than the unsportsmanlike conduct penalty
which i think leads into your player of
the game
well yeah the unsportsmanlike conduct
foul happened after josh allen was
dragged to the ground by aaron donald on
a play that included a sack
a forced fumble and a fumble recovery
that is the defensive lineman trifecta
the only way that gets better is if you
pick it up and rumble bumble and stumble
into the end zone for a touchdown that's
too much to expect
sac
forced fumble fumble recovery and aaron
donald was a force of nature uh
throughout the day look they they double
him they triple him he complained last
week that he doesn't like being
double-teamed he thinks he should be it
should be one-on-one because yeah
there's no one who can handle him
one-on-one and he he was around the
quarterback all day josh allen told me
after the game that before it started he
said to aaron donald take it easy on me
today during the game he knew where
aaron donald was wherever aaron donald
went you have to be aware of where the
guy is and what that does
it makes it harder to play quarterback
when you constantly are thinking where
is 99 where is 99 and one of the things
allen said is if we see them again
we need a better plan for 99. i don't
know that you can have a better plan
because at some point you're devoting so
many resources to stopping him
that you can't stop the other guys who
are coming after josh allen but i agree
with you on josh allen he he has that
escapability and the ability to keep his
eyes down the field and make something
happen when he gets away from the rush
sims and i talked about this earlier
today though with mahomes it's a little
more fluid and it's a little more
certain that he's going to make the
escape and make something good happen
when alan starts into that
it doesn't look
as effortless
it makes you a little more nervous
and you feel like there's a greater
chance that something screwy is going to
happen because i think at times he does
venture a little bit beyond what his
capabilities allow but it's good it's
better to be dancing on that line than
to be too conservative because we see
him fire that ball down the field he
makes great throws he makes great
decisions he doesn't need to have his
feet planted he's a lot like mahomes and
russell wilson in that way where they
can make the funny body throws off of
different arm angles and different
platforms that's what makes him so good
so those were the two players best on
the field by far on
sunday in that game give me someone who
was better or worse than you thought he
was going to be prior to taking a second
look at the the game footage
i think it was daryl henderson and i
don't know if this is sacrilege to say
but i think the rams are a better team
right now with daryl henderson than they
were trying to get the ball to todd
gurley over the last two years with all
his knee issues his first career 100
yard game and he didn't have a whole lot
of yards career yards coming into this
game but boy he ran hard he ran down the
field we know this is a pretty good
defense too and you know it just wasn't
the 32nd ranked defense that he was
running all over but i i just thought he
was really good and he had 167 yards uh
coming into this game and in total in
his career and and just played terrific
so he was is a much better back i think
than i gave him credit for at first
glance
and one of the narratives for the rams
going into this year was the committee
approach wants to be like the 49ers you
don't want to have that star running
back who sucks up all the oxygen all the
attention all the cap space and then
you've got all the eggs in that basket
when that basket breaks you don't have a
running game so they wanted malcolm
brown daryl henderson and cam akers the
problem is acres wasn't able to play
he's got separated rib cartilage keep dr
needle away from him after what happened
last week with tyrod taylor and sorry
and malcolm brown had surgery to repair
a fractured pinky so daryl henderson got
the the bulk of the workload ideally
he's not going to get those
opportunities the other thing is the
bills couldn't stop him the bills
couldn't stop drive to start the second
half the bills are down 21-3 not nearly
as deep of a hole to climb out of is
28-3 they're running the ball
effectively they get to a second and
four they throw they throw they throw
second or third down fourth down just
keep running the damn ball they can't
stop you and to their credit when they
were down 28 to three because the bill
scored a touchdown after that failed
drive the idea was that the rams started
running the ball and they came back and
they they uh took the lead until josh
allen took it back all right uh for me
cole beasley uh i thought that that he
was better on second look because that
guy's just always open whenever you need
him he's there he converted the third
into 22 play he had other big catches
targeted six seven times caught six
passes for a hundred yards so cold you
know all the talk about stefan diggs
cole beasley is still getting it done
for the buffalo bills who had a game
they did more than 22. mike
fourth
and sorry
for colby
you're right a game they'd like to
forget
i'm going to go with jaylen ramsey if
you remember a few years ago he called
josh allen trash and i'm not sure he's
going to be calling josh allen trash
after this game josh allen got him on
some passes and and i just didn't think
that secondary played
very well especially early and then
again late the third quarter they kind
of found themselves but
jalen ramsey ended up with one tackle
one pass defense and it wasn't like they
weren't going to his side because they
did go to his side they did go at him uh
and and he just didn't cover very well
and if you're the highest paid
cornerback in football you need to be
better than that and i just didn't think
he played a very good game and josh
allen got him
and actually it was third and 22 just so
we're accurate it was a 22 play it felt
hopeless it felt as hopeless as fourth
and 22 but it was third and 22. it was
also third and 22 earlier in the quarter
when uh josh allen ended up fumbling the
ball and getting the unsportsmanlike
conduct penalty because he thought he
was illegally horse collared horse
collar tackles are allowed in the pocket
that was a rule the nfl tried to change
a few years ago it didn't change and
even though and this is probably the
only time this is going to happen josh
allen is your player of the game josh
allen is my guy that would would like to
have this one back because there were
aspects of the game that he was upset
about and that's what he told me after
you know guys should be happy no he said
i'm pissed off that we let the 28-3 lead
get away he used language to a referee
that he knows he shouldn't have he's
expecting he gonna find this week for
the unsportsmanlike conduct foul that
happened after he was upset when the
ball came out and he was pulled down by
the back of his jersey and he thought
that he was a legally horse caller and
then
he he had a face mask foul he's getting
two fine letters this week because we
know they they dispense fines as a
automatic proposition for uh face mask
penalties so it's gonna be an expensive
week for josh allen even though they won
he's upset with the way they won 28-3
should have held the offense was as
responsible as the defense for letting
the rams get back into the game so even
though they won he's not happy with it
and he's also not thrilled with the way
they won at the end of the game he told
me about that
that controversial pass interference
call i'm not the kind of guy that likes
to win that way but i'm not going to
complain about it so uh even though it
felt like a loss to him
the bills get a win it was an exciting
game and uh
um
you know the bills keep rolling and
they've got week 8 coming up against the
patriots and week 16 coming up against
the patriots they got a chiefs game
coming up on a thursday night they're
going to get tested again and again and
again and we'll see if josh allen a
company can rise up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports